jennifer je voudrais que l'on s'attarde
un peu sur toi ma chérie puisque tu as
fait plein de choses et c'est vrai que
12 janvier 2011
tu remporté la finale de la star academy
chahdortt la m 2002 preumont midori
c'est vrai excuse moi écrit pan non non
pas du tout mais sera quel âge j'avais
je venais de chagrin 18 ans moi j'étais
j'ai su que j'étais pour toi j'étais à
fond pour toi
[Musique]
on a préparé un magnéto récapitulatif de
tout cas carrière mais tu crois quoi on
s'est fait la malle
3verser min à la sauvette le magnéto
n'est pas du tout j'assume tout à fait
moi je suis très fier d'avoir fait
combien va coûter ce monétaire mais y'a
pas que la star ac qui a tout ce que tu
as fait allez on se retrouve dans une
heure
jennifer est entré dans le coeur des
français en 2001 avec sa participation
au télé crochet star académie
[Applaudissements]
dès lors elle passe en quelques semaines
deux candidates apprécié à artistes
reconnus grâce à son premier album vendu
à plus d'un million d'exemplaires avec
ce single au soleil
[Musique]
jenifer c'est plus de 2,3 millions
d'albums vendus neuf albums de platine
et plus de vingt-cinq single
[Musique]
jenifer c'est aussi 16 participation aux
[ __ ]
[Musique]
quatre participations en tant que coach
à l'émission the voice
[Musique]
et environ 16 1534 couverture de télé 7
jours
[Musique]
les
des gestes
geoffrey
[Musique]
mais c'est vrai que je déteste
l'émission parce que je déteste quand on
utilise des enfants c'est pour moi ce
sont voilà c'est un peu les singes
habillé on les fait chanter ça parce
qu'ils chantent ils sont trop jeunes
pour vivre un ascenseur émotionnel c'est
la première chose s'ils choisissent
fumer c'est la première chaîne d'europe
donc soit ça marche c'est trop jeune
pour les starisé cirque après on sait
très bien ce que ça donne aussi des
enfants stars ce que vous vous êtes
annonce expériences n'ont pas tellement
mais je serai apte à une erreur est ce
qu'il faisait ce que vous voulez est une
enfant star vous paraît alors pas du
tout vous voulez pas faire des trucs
genre dont les groupes puissent un sac
série de la chaîne pense à tous à
l'émission à tour en fait sauf aux
enfants si j'avais été viré ils peuvent
très mal le vivre et s'ils deviennent
star c'est trop tôt pour être star leur
voix n'est pas prêt je n'aurais pas
participer à ce programme s'il avait pas
de la bd en veillant cécile les enfants
n'étaient pas accompagnés c'est un court
mais jennifer vous savez vraiment ce
qu'il devienne un an après deux ans un
probable grand disent rien c'est
extraordinaire un plateau télé donc déjà
ils ont des papillons des yeux parce que
parce qu'ils y participent déjà un radio
crochet à un télé crochet complètement
extraordinaire avec des musiciens qui
jouent en live
il s'exprime justement je les sors
aujourd'hui en chansons ils sont trés
accompagné de différents produits et les
réseaux sociaux les encourage surtout
pas à construire une carrière absolument
pas non non les suffrages à s'épanouir
dans cette sorte repartent donc avec
cette expérience
et après il n'y a pas du tout de ça
c'est sûr il est encore là ce qu'on a
levé 4 de the voice aux chaînes
confondues amel bent a dit dans une
interview qu'elle avait accepté
participent à des missions qu
appartement il y avait eu un suivi
psychologique des enfants 6 euros après
l'émission près de suri ce n'est pas
tout à fait vrai mais bien sûr rien du
futur qui a suivi il ya même la famille
qui est très présente vraiment il ya une
notion d' équipe en fait malgré la
grosse machinerie effectivement qu'était
fait les gros plateaux télé avec tout ce
flou sur six est à retirer autour d'eux
mais ils sont très accompagné non au
contraire
[Musique]
je me suis dit